who's the best player you've had to play  against and Rena Rogers please talk  about that oh man he's a phenomenal boy  I could tell you one plea presence white  guy lined up on 17 right so I'm  disguising I'm kind of down towards the  box but I'm actually going back for some  reason I'm in the stance and I'm never  in this stance a try look at me and  smile and kind of give like a look  giggle and this did something with his  hand 217 I knew it was a signature 17 I  looked at 17 I looked at my guy that's  covering them I see as soon as you say  Hut I try to run before you say Hut he  already said it I'm already out leverage  touchdown 217 over my god so just just a  mindset his preparation for the game his  ability to move out the pocket and throw  off his back for you never seen quite a  big city besides I think Brett fought  off his back foot like he does and he's  just a great guy